[Music]
and it counts news submitted by mr.
Roger Rogers Roger I love that man do
rest of peace my dude nicest person in
the world I don't know about you madam
no I mean like I've read so many stories
like mr. Roger he is I see Roger
mr. Rogers I Larry [ __ ] all I know is
that you affected my childhood in a very
positive way I [ __ ] love your name
Roger
no it's person is mister and he put
cardigans on Mac every time there you go
it was a guy named les [ __ ] I
think each cardigan was made by his
grandmother or something yeah a court
has ruled that an unsent text message is
valid as a last will and testament
what house okay this is very specific
how that works how that might work yeah
cuz I mean they're still writing it like
you don't have to send your will to
someone right I've been doing that a lot
lately though you were writing will no
unsent text messages yeah I keep writing
it and then don't press send and I move
on Oh I wake up to sound touch message
read remind myself suggesting later and
then never so bad I just touched my
friend back I'm like a petite sex me a
month ago you know what I do to avoid
that I just turn on the read like read
that's how you guys always see my text I
don't tell you if I read it or did it
mmm then if I read it then they'll be
like hey you read it you forgot about my
oh yeah you're right before what if you
like you're trying to ignore them I have
my my ways of that do you turn it off
and then you read it no no no no you
just said per-person right can't you do
that per person scientists I don't know
this is how you go to that option where
you openly said you just ignore
everything anyways this family feud
okay so this 55 year old man from
Australia took his own life took his own
life in October last year ah yeah and so
he wrote in that unsent text that his
brother and nephew quote keep all they
should keep all I have house what what
hello Chinese now dear what the hell
[Laughter]
should keep all that I have house and
superannuation put my ashes in the back
garden and he said that his wife should
take her stuff only she's ellipses gone
back to her ex again I'm beaten and then
he ends it up he ends it with his bank
details before signing off my will with
a smiley face so that would be on centre
who was he supposed to send me to that's
a good question and doesn't say who the
recipient was that's [ __ ] validus
[ __ ] and then so this so now the widow
supported by his son from a previous
relationship so not her son they argue
that the text messages should not be
treated as his final will why so she
could take his [ __ ] the sudden she wants
it [ __ ] go back to your [ __ ] it's part
of the reason why I killed him she's the
reason why he killed himself
dad please [ __ ] left me went back to
the same dick she been sucking 30 years
ago again and then he gets mad and you
killed himself
oh he's probably said yes apparently the
woman the widow she's particularly she's
attaching a particular significance to
the fact that the deceased did not send
the text message so should not but you
bounced Shirdi makes me want to kill
myself and [ __ ] her yeah she's probably
like well what if he was typing it but
decided to change his mind so he didn't
send it that's that's argument okay
that's exactly right guys
suicide suicide is not a joke all I'm
saying is if you ever feel the need to
kill yourself because your wife left you
or anything like that go to Del Taco
again chill what a man you just said
you're not making what do I do in up I'd
say this if your wife leaves you just
know that you know just know it's a
blessing in the mirror it's always a
blessing [ __ ] probably was sucking so
much [ __ ] dick her [ __ ] mouth just
smells like piss so
but that's how I get over breakups
though I put that person in the worst
light in my head we could have had a
great a macabre amicable breakup but
what I do is I make this person evil as
[ __ ] until I get over my dog she didn't
know no she didn't it doesn't [ __ ]
matter but I want to make our breakup as
easy as possible so you have to look
like a [ __ ] scumbag I feel like
people need to understand that divorces
are equipping a very good thing yeah
yeah it sucks didn't work out but now
yes I'm going do your own separate ways
sometimes some people just get divorced
all the time and they have to realize
they're not made to be with somebody you
just [ __ ] stay by yourself and die
because you're boring or or just mean
yeah that's the way they're mean like
what are you waiting for
okay so this couple they had been
married for a year and in a relationship
for three years and seven months and
that they had problems and the wife had
left on at least three occasional [ __ ]
in in a short amount of time
oh yeah yeah yeah and then so she wants
everything they also they're saying that
the widow did move out that she had
moved out but she still made
arrangements to take the deceased to his
mental health appointments and that they
had spent the weekend prior to his death
together cleaning garden clippings and
boxing books for lifeline I'm not sure
what I claimed well yeah so like they
did spend time together and I guess
she's arguing like I was still involved
in his life like it doesn't matter he
still didn't want you to have the stuff
you [ __ ] succubus yeah cos yeah he
specifically said nothing yeah yeah what
I don't understand is how does guarding
clippings and [ __ ] like that constant to
her [ __ ] entitlement to any of the
family Jews that doesn't mean you
[ __ ] out he'd never be left each
other so you know what I should get 50%
if you loved each other that was a great
memory how the [ __ ] does that go into
the bank account listen I don't
understand now she had an argument like
yeah okay we fought but guess what
I helped him build his [ __ ] donut
shop from the ground up [ __ ]
where we were married
[ __ ] didn't know how to do in
the accountant I work the register that
[ __ ] bozo was just making a dump if
that was the case of course [ __ ] the
will she made a lot of that money
because she helped the business in
finding yeah well the judge see she
ended up saying that the evidence that
was presented to her did not establish
the fact that this woman did in fact go
back to her ex-husband or that she even
had any relationship with him other than
one of friendship and so I don't know it
just it all boils down to the fact that
they did accept this yeah good if I
divorced my wife she is not getting
anything they were divorced no she left
him Oh [ __ ] then you definitely gone
dude what about divorced with good terms
I don't never believe in that [ __ ] with
your kids
mister those are the only two people I
know that are very professional mr. Wynn
of the Wynn hotels his wife still works
within him they work together but they
not together mr. Rock mr. Dwayne want
Watson Johnson Dwayne Johnson I I know
from a reputable source named Bart Kwan
owe me that the rock and the wife worked
together
she's his manager she they're divorced
really he's uh kissing she's really cool
with like his new wife that's really
cool I like that I don't know but I just
know that his ex-wife is his manager in
that case she helped him be who he is
and if he dies even though they're not
married I think you'll be fair to give
her something yeah
dude I wish I had an ounce of the rocks
work ethic dude he is such a hard
[ __ ] worker man dude this guy's over
here putting metal chains on his neck
for no goddamn reason
that's my neck hurts my neck yeah he's
like the [ __ ] little you know workout
[ __ ] wakes up at 4:00 a.m. to train on
he's so positive all the time
he's like the [ __ ] black Samoan Kasey
nice tat dude yes so positive inspiring
I feel like if I ever see him cry I
would cry dude he had to eat like
potatoes all day or something that was a
Stone Cold Steve Austin oh yeah I knew
it was some wrestler yeah
Stone Cold Steve Austin ate raw potatoes
cuz he couldn't afford [ __ ] he couldn't
afford like gas electricity or nothing
you must have had how the diarrhea he
said he still eats raw potatoes till
this day cuz he still likes me raw oh I
like those stories I don't you say have
you guys they've done anything that I
prepare for your own I've never done
just started oh I do what we just met
with our accountant slash financial
planner and then he says it's about time
they you guys gotta start this already
well because I have a kid now okay
so that when you have a kid you want to
like already just have like assume and
plan for the worst of the worst and then
so you want to figure out how things are
gonna move and we have businesses
together and all that stuff so you want
to just you want to take all of the when
you're not emotionally charged have all
the logistics planned so that when
something that's emotional happens you
don't make stupid decisions and things
can just move a twosie according to plan
and you can pretty much like be
hands-off what have you guys planned out
we just had this conversation but we
need a plan like for example who's the
caretaker if one of us passes away who's
a caretaker both of us pass away wait if
one of you pass away wouldn't the other
oh yeah yeah that [ __ ] that up but
like something like that and then like a
who handles the finances because what
for hot what he has what he has is
someone's gonna take care of his kids
before they turn 18 at that time and
someone else was gonna handle their
finances because one person was like you
know as family I would love to take care
of your kids but I don't want to have
anything to do with finances and another
family knows I'll take care of the
finances for like pay this pay that
whatever so
that comes I'm like how much you leave
protecting when you touch that money and
what goes to what ins that yeah yeah I
didn't go that beep I just thing on
Facebook that lets you have like a a
legacy part where you put people in
charge of your Facebook account after
you die yes and that's my little sister
instruction I'll buy it
my crystal crystal oh my god she keeps
on posting as me free Alysia but i'm not
i'm nothing too deep III have my nephew
on as the person to take over my pension
after I die I hope he doesn't kill me no
ever since I was 18 ever since I was
born I had always wanted to get at least
life insurance nothing I don't tell I
don't know why I still haven't done it
to this day
my dad's crazy thing you're only 21 my
dad is my dad is so crazy he's like so I
got this life insurance right if I died
before 60 years old you get all this
money I was like don't do that so I hope
I die soon like would you stop that
please like I don't want you to do that
that's [ __ ] tight oh that's all real
he's hyping himself you burn people
while you talk no I mean like cuz he bit
because he'd been at me side headed a
dog yeah he's on both so like he has
this thing where it's like he texted me
one 90s okay if I ever get really sick
and I'm about to die can you just let me
die like a G I was like what
yes baby be a G like Yousaf 40 yeah you
think he's like don't like on us at 8
don't put me on tubes I want to go out
like a warrior I'm like why I don't know
why people say [ __ ] like that nowadays I
want to go out like a war [ __ ] is mm
[ __ ] 7 my dad's from a different time
do you know your dad is not from 500
years ago differently from my dad well
he didn't grow up 500 years ago what I'm
saying same like the way that he was
raised like like in the streets coming
from another country war-torn country he
grew I know but the word warrior is such
I know but everybody uses that still
that is there I want to go out like a
[ __ ] warrior well we never were
warriors oh no we're not doing that he
doesn't want to be on tubes I like I
want to go out like a [ __ ] G
that makes more sense because that's
relative Oh
that's what you said you put a couple
bandanas on him yeah he just didn't want
to be like whooping himself and someone
else maybe anybody wants to I wouldn't
want to put myself to death either just
[ __ ] kill me now kill me but to kill
me to kill me well we have to right like
what do we do if we end up like being
like wow yeah like what do we want to do
now do we pull the plug in our stuff
there's like a whole packet lost like
every it's a grown-up [ __ ] bro yeah
because like let's say I pass right all
night and pass by my mom for the
eggplant now do I want to drain all of
the money that we've earned together or
do I want to bounce for me I would just
want to you gotta go he's you know
breathing it's all just like brain
activity you know just saying the tooth
this is all like I picture him like
nearly dead and it's like well in the
world did you like this what was that
I go like this and I like look at that
thing about taco man he's still
breathing his brandish'd it vide and you
can talk that's fine thanks for watching
guys and those are our thoughts what are
your thoughts don't forget to comment
below we want to know what you guys are
thinking but don't write anything that
will make it sad or make us mad because
after all we're just kidding news and
we're a very happy channel for the last
video click up here
[Music]